SPEAKER: Today on
"Cloud Storage Bytes,"
we're going to go where a lot
of web devs would rather not go.
We're talking about CORS, and
we're going to do it twice.
In true storage by
its fashion, I'll
be with you every
step of the way.
So keep calm and stay tuned for
part 1 of our CORS adventure.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Contrary to what other
web devs might tell you,
CORS is a security
feature of browsers
and not just a frustration
dream come to life.
First, I'll give an
overview of what CORS is.
Then I'll address how to
implement CORS for Google Cloud
Storage objects.
Let's get to the basics
of understanding CORS.
First of all, CORS is short for
Cross-Origin Resource Sharing.
To understand what
this means, it really
helps to first understand
same origin resource sharing.
The same origin policy
is a security policy
enforced on web browsers
to prevent interactions
between resources from
different origins, like domains.
I like to think of it as
preventing a bait and switch.
If I go to a website,
say, cat.pics,
I expect to interact with
resources of cat.pics.
But what if cat.pics,
instead of showing photos
of adorable cats, downloaded
malicious software
from some other website?
The same origin policy
looks at the calls that
are coming from a
website and ensures
they come from, you guessed
it, the same origin.
So the same origin
policy is a good thing.
It protects users.
However, it can also prevent
legitimate interactions
between known origins.
For example, a script
on a page hosted
on App Engine at
example.appspot.com
might need to use resources
stored in a Cloud Storage
bucket at
example.storage.googleapis.com.
These are two different
origins from the perspective
of the browser.
Thanks to that trusty same
origin policy, the browser
won't allow a script
from example.appspot.com
to fetch resources from
example.storage.googleapis.com.
You've probably experienced
this as a CORS error.
Admittedly, not ideal,
but take a deep breath.
What does this mean
and how do we fix it?
The Cross-Origin
Resource Sharing spec,
also known as CORS, was
developed by the Worldwide Web
Consortium to get around the
limitations of same origin
policy.
Cloud storage supports CORS
by allowing you to configure
your buckets to support it.
So in our example
case, you can configure
the
example.storage.googleapis.com
bucket so that a
browser can share
its resources with the scripts
from example.appspot.com.
And there you go,
no more CORS error.
Now that you know a
bit more about CORS,
you're ready to get configuring.
There's plenty more to come
about resource sharing,
but we're saving
that for next week.
If you want to know more
about cloud storage and CORS
and don't want to
wait for part 2,
check out the links
in the description.
Don't forget to
subscribe, give us a like,
and tell us what you want to
learn about cloud storage.
Thanks for joining us for this
quick byte of cloud storage.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]